las vegas protesters stand in solidarity
with the families of dante wright and
adam toledo
thank you for joining us tonight at 11
o'clock i'm sasha loftis
the 20 year old and 13 year old were
both shot and killed by police this week
this comes as calls for justice built
across the country a final verdict is
expected
next week in the trial of former
minneapolis police officer derek chovin
we saw tensions here locally last summer
but this is the first demonstration
we've had
since the strip reopened a tourist
madison kimbrough joins us live tonight
with the latest on this
madison yes even with the hustle and
bustle here on the strip with cars
flying by and people talking amongst
themselves
it was easy to hear chanting going on in
the background
take a look at the footage that we shot
earlier we were across the street from
where the protesters were marching
they began near the bellagio around 7
p.m and then headed
south on las vegas boulevard towards
aria the protest was hosted by a group
named more than a hashtag
lv many protesters with megaphones
chanting
say his name dante wright and posters in
hand
read we believe racism must end we won't
stop
no justice no peace metro police were on
bikes following the crowd
as they peacefully marched from our
perspective since we were across the
street
it was a little bit hard to see who was
actually marching
in the protest and who was just casually
walking on the strip but from our
perspective it looked like it was about
75 to 100 people
involved in the protest reporting live
on the las vegas strip madison kimbrough
8 news